[Musique]
alors gilles girard président de la rive
par l'association intercommunale de la
pêche et de la culture de l'art de la
règle
le salon au point où c'est au bout de
dix ans maintenant elle savait disant
que larry pas existe pour nous c'est un
tremplin pour faire connaître tout ce
qu'on fait tout ce que larry pas fait
depuis dix ans on est arrivé à un au
boudin d'avancé que maintenant on
produit on transforme souvent en exporte
aux faits tout le salon pour nous c'est
un moyen de nous faire connaître un peu
plus tiré sur le marché européen et
métropolitains
le village réunion il est immense il est
superbe
franchement franchement pourra dire de
plus il ya toute la réunion qui
représentait au niveau à art et culture
fruits légumes seraient enola larripa
mais on remercie le département la
chambre d'agriculture que depuis je
travaille avec le plus d'envié depuis
deux ans depuis qu'il est évident qu'on
ne tire que s'ils pouvaient surtout vers
les plats et vraiment ça nous rennais se
croirait vraiment service des plats et
ça fait chaud au coeur d'être là
[Musique]